bonjour sow agba baysa merci beaucoup
d'être en direct ce matin avec nous sur
rt france le mouvement de contestation
est né il ya plus de deux ans maintenant
c'était le 16 février 2019
ou est-ce qu'on en est de ce combat
aujourd'hui comme vous l'avez vu le
combat is poursuit le peuple algérien
n'a pas l'intention de se taire et il le
peuple algérien où qu'ils se trouvent
que ce soit sur le territoire algérien
que ce soir et à travers les différentes
diasporas travers le monde
ils soutiennent le peuple algérien mais
il est en complète connexion avec lui et
si tous les mardis et tous les vendredis
ça se fasse à travers toutes les villes
d'algérie ça continue aussi pendant les
week-ends à se poursuivre dans les
villes de france au canada aux états
unis en italie les diasporas sont de
tout coeur avec leurs frères et leur
soeur de l'autre côté de la méditerranée
et pourquoi ça ne s'était pas parce que
ce pouvoir est toujours en place et
qu'il n'est pas à l'écouté des
revendications du peuple algérien qui
veut que ce système politique sa ré est
de plus en plus au fur et à mesure des
années nous voyons un président et un
gouvernement qui ne vont que vers des
élections des propositions d'élections
alors qu'ils sont dans les légitimités
parce que ils ne sont pas dans les
revendications que réclame le peuple
algérien c'est à dire nappe mal de ce
système politique et d'arriver vraiment
à la mise en place d'un état de droit et
une véritable citoyenneté et la
répression ou thynnus poursuit vous
l'avez rappelé en début de votre journal
qu'il y a encore des détenus d'opinion
des détenus d'opinion qui sont en grève
de la faim et que ce même gouvernement a
même tenté la répression contre les
diasporas en tentant de mettre de faire
une loi pour déchéance de la nationalité
à tous ceux qui s'expriment dé dans les
diasporas donc des personnes comme vous
risquerez la déchéance de la
personnalité
la pénalité oui voilà ils ont tenté bon
le projet de loi a été retiré parce que
ça c'est soulever des journalistes ont
heureusement que des voix se sont
élevées mais vous voyez jusqu'où va la
répression c'est à dire que même en
étant binationaux sur d'autres dans
d'autres pays
dès lors qu'on s'exprime et que l'on
comptait fait que l'on soutient le
peuple algérien on est on est
susceptible d'avoir de la répression
mais est-ce qu'il faut dire aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il ya une grave crise politique
économique et sociale et en ce premier
jour de ramadhan en algérie
les prix flambent la la crise économique
est présente et on a toujours à
président de la république illégitime
avec un gouvernement illégitime qui se
maintiennent au pouvoir et qui ne
veulent pas entendre les revendications
du peuple algérien et elles sont claires
ils ont donné la feuille de route
ils veulent une transition démocratique
ils veulent passer par une constituante
et ne veulent plus des tenants de ce
régime
monsieur t boudent ressemble à ses
prédécesseurs il est même encore pire
dans la répression que ses prédécesseurs
des slogans anti français sont entendus
de plus en plus au cours de ces
mobilisations pourquoi sans vous mais je
pense que les slogans qui français sont
comme tous les slogans contre le fait
que des pouvoirs étrangers soutiennent
et à porte caution en donnant une
légitimité au gouvernement tebboune
c'est pour ça qu'il y assez sot grand
mais je ne pense pas que ça soit ni
contre les français ni contre ' les
populations puisqu'il existe des
solidarités internationales
c'est aux dirigeants d'arrêter de
soutenir et de deux d'apporter une
caution à ce gouvernement est d'être
vraiment à l'écouté du pouvoir du peuple
algérien nous savons très bien nous ne
sommes pas dupes qu'il y a des intérêts
géostratégiques
il y as besoin les états européens ont
besoin d'assurer la sécurité à leurs
frontières
on a besoin d'eux
canaliser le flux d'immigration dont ça
passe par des tractations avec les
pouvoirs politiques mais aujourd'hui
donner caution au gouvernement tebboune
ca peux dire c'est un peu envoyez un
message en disant aux peuples qui se
révoltent rentrez chez vous c'est
terminé voilà ses valets danse est mieux
là autre particularité du mouvement
aujourd'hui dans un cadre du fils le
front islamique du salut qui on s'en
souvient et était ce parti a interdit en
algérie en 1992 et qui avait provoqué à
la guerre sanglante avec le gia ferait
partie aujourd'hui des rangs du
mouvement est ce que vous nous confirmer
cette information
alors il peut il ne faut pas leur donner
plus d'importance qu'il me dit mon nom
mais il ne faut pas aussi les
sous-estimer parce que il faut rappeler
et vous l'avez dit au début de votre
reportage ce mouvement populaire ce
mouvement révolutionnaire n'a été à
l'instar donc un mouvement politique ni
d'autre qu'un mouvement syndical donc
aujourd'hui il n'y a aucun mouvement
scène politique qui peut revendiquer
qu'il est le déclencheur de ce mouvement
un révolutionnaire
j'en récupère est d'être infiltrées par
people
il tente de récupérer ils tentent de
récupérer et vous savez ce que je vais
dire est très important parce que les
partis islamistes de toute façon ce sont
des mouvances qui marchent main dans la
main avec le pouvoir exemple toujours
marcher main dans la main avec le bois
est en fait il se sauve l autre quand
urdin qui va pour disparaître l'autre le
saut et aujourd'hui nous ressortir les
islamistes pour faire peur en disant que
ça va être le chaos c'est soit nous les
islamistes avec le avec le chaos
c'est une façon de faire peuple au on
peut de faire peur au peuple algérien
mais le peuple algérienne n'est pas dupe
il sait très bien ce qu'il a vécu
pendant la décennie noire et il ne
laissera pas passer une mouvance comme
celle là certes ils ont un impact si
vous voulez ils ont gagné une bataille
idéologique dans le fait que des
questions comme la séparation du
politique et du religieux
de la laïcité et cetera sont des sujets
qu'ils ne veulent pas aborder tout comme
la question de l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes mais aujourd'hui il
utilise des moyens avec le pouvoir en
faisant croire que la démocratie ce sont
les élections et nous savons très bien
ce qui peut être fait avec un outil
comme les élections or on rappelle
toujours que la démocratie ne s'arrête
pas aux élections la démocratie ce sont
des préalables comme la mise en place
des libertés individuelles et
collectives dont la liberté de
conscience l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes et la justice sociale donc à
part les partis islamistes ne pourront
plus jouer comme ils ont joué et c'est
pour ça qu'ils font partie de tout ce
système à battre parce qu'ils font
partie du système
ils ne sont pas en dehors du système
politique qui existe aujourd'hui ils
sont partie prenante de ce système merci
beaucoup soad baba aïssa d'avoir répondu
ce matin en direct à nos questions sur
arte france